Bienvenido o bienvenida en este programa formativo de HobbyCode.
Primero de todo, darte las gracias por haber confiado en nosotros.
Y lo segundo que te quiero decir es que has tomado la mejor decisión que puedas haber tomado
porque este camino es un camino en el cual está demostrado,
en el cual tenemos grandes posibilidades para poder ser rentables en los mercados financieros
y lo más importante, estás aquí porque has decidido automatizar tu trading.
No solo tu trading, que el cual ya estás haciendo ya o a lo mejor no,
sino el hecho de querer encontrar nuevas estrategias y que esas estrategias puedan operar en los mercados
de forma automatizada por nosotros, compatibilizar el trading con tu trabajo
o cualquier motivo que tengas para haber entrado con nosotros,
estás en el sitio correcto para aprender a crear nuevas estrategias de trading totalmente automatizadas.
A partir de ahora empieza un tiempecito para ti en el cual vas a tener que dedicarle cierta dedicación semanal
para poder aprender todos los conceptos que te voy a ir enseñando,
tanto yo como el equipo, acerca de nuestro trading algonímico,
acerca de nuestra metodología de 12 pasos.
Verás que la metodología de 12 pasos es el core en el cual nos basamos
para poder crear sistemas que puedan tener altas probabilidades de ser rentables de cara al futuro.
Pero no solo eso, sino que aquí encontrarás formación secundaria o digamos extratroncal de lo que es el programa formativo
para que complemente de la mejor forma posible todos los conocimientos que necesitas para entender la formación troncal.
Verás que iremos paso a paso, verás que primero enseñaremos las herramientas a utilizar,
primero aprenderás los conceptos que necesitamos tener claros para luego aprender la metodología de 12 pasos.
Está estructurado de tal forma para que si ves todo el contenido de forma secuencial,
tengas los conocimientos necesarios antes de entender lo que viene después.
Así que nada, te deseo lo mejor ánimo y esfuerzo posible que puedas tener a partir de ahora.
Seguro que si el mundo del trading y sobre todo el triángulo anímico te gusta y te apasiona,
esto va a ser muy fácil de aprender para ti.
Pero simplemente un mensaje que te quiero dar.
No lo dejes de lado, intenta dedicar semana a semana un tiempo por parte tuya
porque el hecho de estar conectado a semana a semana va a ser que sea mucho más fácil
el aprendizaje de todos los conceptos que te vamos a enseñar en las próximas semanas que vienen.
Que sepas que esto es un contenido un poco distinto a lo que sueles ver en las redes sociales
de una estrategia, la implementas y ya está.
Esto es un nivel más, no de complejidad, sino que es otros conceptos.
El hecho de poder operar de forma automatizada los mercados financieros,
pero está preparado para que cualquier persona que tenga unas mínimas bases de trading
pueda absorber de forma correcta en el tiempo que nosotros hemos estimado
todo este conocimiento que tenemos preparado para ti.
Así que a partir de ahora empieza un camino muy emocionante
y seguro, seguro, seguro que en un tiempo, en cuestión de meses,
podrás operar ya de forma automatizada en una de tus cuentas reales
y puedas saborear el hecho de qué es esto de que un robot me abra una operación
de forma automatizada mientras yo estoy trabajando, durmiendo o estoy haciendo otras cosas.
Pronto te va a llegar esa situación, pero lo primero de todo es centrarte en tu aprendizaje,
esfuerzo y, lo más importante, actitud.
Que tengas mucho esfuerzo, suerte no es necesario que te la dé porque estás en el sitio correcto,
pero sí mucha actitud y verás que pronto podrás operar de forma automatizada.